we're getting one step closer to the
pre-crime in Minority Report where is
mobile warrants will give police the
ability to enter a private residence
anywhere at any time but does making a
warrant acquisition easier for policeman
justice will be better served in Butte
County police no longer need to
physically get a judge's signature to
execute a search warrant they can do it
all on their iphone all right so this
story combines a lot of my favorite
stuff the debate that we're always
having about privacy technology the
future on its face this seems scary to
me the idea I get it we're all walking
around with phones so if a cop wants to
get in someone's house instead of having
to go to the judge and go through the
process they can just do it on their
phone and that's the way technology is
going so okay but on the other side of
it is maybe having that moment to go to
the cop having that time that allows our
system to have some correction in it and
that we shouldn't just be allowing our
law enforcement to just be willy-nilly
like literally clicking a button having
a judge or a robot somewhere click
another button to say okay you have the
warrant go for it so I there's something
about this that I don't like knowing the
trends that we have in general about
privacy and things ya know I think it's
I think it's an interesting thought but
I think the cops you want these warrants
are gonna get them either way right you
still have to go to a judge thankfully
and I don't think but you can do it all
on your phone you don't actually have to
like file a paper somewhere you could be
on the fly doing this you know like how
we order pizzas um you know and if you
know if they're if they're hunting down
a serious criminal and and there's some
sort of timing issue I think this is a
great thing you know I mean you know
someone like Robert Durst but you know
giving police more power to do their job
in ways that harm people's civil
liberties that does scare me ah okay so
we she got there I didn't know if she
was gonna come with yeah yeah I see this
as a is it makes no difference you know
the Internet's faster the world is
faster everything's worse because it's
faster we talked about that last time we
were on yes
so really you know just as a test what I
did was I called into this location here
it's a mobile meth lab I wanted to test
but you know really what are we doing it
was a great you know when you do this
show the producers of the show send you
links to the articles and the topics and
I was reading on the right website the
great article about this and they talked
about some of the specifics where all
they're able to do with this is cut down
the lag time for where a meth lab can
then flush the drugs right that's right
that I think is important exactly right
so I really what's change though so they
can get the warrant faster so if they're
coming in to get you and you're
completely innocent of everything and
it's the your at the same name as a
criminal your name just happened to be
you know Jose whatever Colombian drug a
drug dude right unfortunately for you
and you were raised Jewish which makes
no sense it just means that that mistake
is just gonna happen faster it's not
gonna change the outcome of it you'll be
exonerated right so I get that part and
that's what you were saying yes but I do
have this I always have the concept of
the slippery slope yes suddenly they
that we have issues with law enforcement
and trust of law enforcement right now
and that we're just giving them more
power to quickly do things and how do we
unravel that if it gets out of control
yeah but but the reality is is that
right and and but you know this is just
one more thing we're gonna have to keep
an eye on yeah like we don't have enough
to do away yeah how many eyes do we have
no cuz I'm running out of why I like to
accurately think in a 360 yeah does
anyone behind me right now do some of
these cameras there's nobody behind you
there might be any way digital search
warrants I guess there's something good
there but it seems like a slippery slope
what do you think